welcome back to the Daily Show lobby
well he was just in studio with Dave he
is a presidential candidate when the
most famed neurosurgeons in America dr.
ben Carson all right all right all right
this is very exciting so I'm thinking to
myself this morning you know one of
things I love about dr. Carson is that
he is an outsider running to hopefully
change Washington DC and I love that
that's what our founders wanted citizen
leaders but I was thinking to myself
you've been out campaigning for a while
doc and you are a surgeon by trade I
want to make sure you're not losing that
groundedness so I thought let's
challenge him to a game of operation
that's what we're gonna do I'm terrible
and really shaky I'll pull a card first
I'll go first because I think I know how
this is gonna turn out here we go the
card is butterflies in the stomach I've
got butterflies in my fingers all right
let's see where is it doc okay oh boy
all right
look do you see me shake it I'm never
nervous I'm never nervous oh just like
that I'm out all right your card sir
first card 0 for Ken brain freeze brain
freeze for the brain surgeon
see what I did there putting the
pressure on him alright here we go
how do you feel are you nervous at all
nah it's not brain surgery oh did you
catch that all right here he goes oh my
gosh folks look at that no problem
alright if you're keeping score at home
one for dr. Carson zero for me next one
up oh jeez the broken heart which is
what I'm gonna have when this is over
let's see I can't even get that do you
see that
I see why am I wasting at me oh my gosh
I'm shaking like crazy
alright wishbone wishbone here he goes
if you get this the game's over you
pretty much knocked me out where's the
wishbone oh do you hear that I might
have a chance
neurosurgeon old school operation tell
us what you're doing I'm trying to move
it into position he's moving it into
position
oh did you see that here we go I got a
hurry spareribs here we go oh do you see
this it's unbelievable I can't stop
shaking
all right he's got to close this one out
what is it writers cramp writers cramp
under pressure David how much time do we
have 40 seconds well this is almost
impossible folks oh there it is but
here's the good news here's the good
news he won we got we got 30 seconds
what would you say to Americans Oh why
they should vote for you
well I would say that I have a long
history of solving problems for instance
I would widen this thing right here but
but really experience comes from a wide
variety of different things and you know
I've had an opportunity to work for
decades and corporate America start a
national non-profit nine of ten of which
fail that is one major national awards
done many complex operations gotten lots
of people involved and recognized that
you can't do it all by yourself you have
to take advantage of the smart people
around you there it is folks big car
said live on the Dave Ramsey show